if you say that vaccination is safe and
we're monitoring its safety
wouldn't it be easier for the government
to make it more or less mandatory
or if not forcing people strongly
compelling them
as in israel if you don't want to be
vaccinated
don't leave your house
russia has extensive experience in
nationwide vaccination
we have got used to its voluntary nature
i think trying to pressure force people
to get the jab
or stay at home because they haven't
been inoculated that's wrong because
everyone is different
we're now seeing a scandal unfolding
around the astrazeneca vaccine while the
who
says that it's too early to draw any
conclusions and suspending it may be
unnecessary what do you think what is
your general
attitude to this scandal
we are extremely careful when it comes
to any data connected to side effects
potentially provoked by this or that
product why
because we do not have the opportunity
to fully check it using medical data
in this case we can only speak about
ourselves and here i can say that each
country is strictly monitoring all of
the potential post-vaccination side
effects
the vaccination process should not be
politicized because the process itself
is aimed at one particular goal
saving lives and protecting the
population
are we not politicizing this as a
country
we are saying that the country created
three products of its own
we're telling the whole world about them
in the same way that everyone else is
why wouldn't we it's our achievement
we're proud of it
at the end of the day it's an appraisal
of russian science which some have been
trying to diminish
and say we are not capable of anything
we are
in the long run we do acknowledge that
there could be a third wave
there may be a slight increase but why
is it massive
everywhere but moderate in russia well
we see how the epidemiological situation
is developing in europe and in russia
one of the reasons for this development
is that they were constantly in lockdown
people stayed at home they did not go
outside they are sterile in the sense of
the virus
then they go out and catch it that's why
they never developed collective immunity
right
essentially yes when do you think this
will all end
we are now working on the assumption
that we will achieve 60
collective immunity by august it is
clear that most likely
there will be some seasonality everyone
has been talking about that
so it could come back in october
yes but i really hope people will get
vaccinated because dealing with the
consequences of the disease
will be far more difficult than getting
voluntarily inoculated
you